[Music]
[Music]
fire
stop
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
we're out come on baby
TJ Miller wow three glasses three yeah
it is interesting official yeah
I know I know you're used to these big
movie sets up like this big big deal
here dude this is a big deal thick boy
Studios what's up brother how are you
man just maybe you didn't know this
couple Denver thick boys a couple of
Denver thick boys
I looked at him
yeah that's right 52.80 you know what I
did I looked at him and I went TJ you're
big and he and he just reached over and
patted me on the shoulder he went ah
you're a good kid well I don't know what
to do I mean I'm not gonna hug you
because I might hurt you it just went
and and it's also it's also a big
Scandinavian brain yeah yeah but I don't
know how you'd react to it too because
I'm sure not too many 55 year old men go
oh man you're big yeah but I saw in man
tears sometimes if a man's handsome
enough he'll give a second Gander oh
damn right I recorded my stand-up yeah
no this guy will oh yeah yeah we used to
tour together we'd be on a plane like a
big athletic black guy come on like what
are you what are you in the NFL like
what no yeah
do you remember the first time I met you
this is the strangest thing oh no we're
in the back of Jeremy piven's back no
that's right we were doing a movie
called the goods and I met TJ kids died
yeah so weird like a piggyback yup uh
and Jerry Piven doesn't remember that
which I think is funny but I saw him
once I was like I was strapped your back
in the goods and he was like huh that
was it and he's like oh very cool that's
all and then did he go I do stand up too
TJ yeah well it was at a comment it was
at the Laugh Factory that's where I met
him and talked to him he's really
interested I mean he was really like I'd
love to get your number and talk to you
sit down and have coffee or whatever
um this is a really nice guy yep but um
yeah I was strapped his back as a
parachute instructor and Neil Brennan
who directed it had he's great he's so
funny and he did a really funny thing
where we did went taking then he came
over and he was like don't
don't make any faces or anything and I
was like oh he's like you've got a goofy
weird face anyway just like don't he's
right Neil's Neil likes that subtle
don't don't kill the Lily don't push the
yeah but he also he didn't kill the Lily
on [ __ ] he did Kill The Lily on telling
me I have a weird looking face and that
was like the second movie I was in or
something like that but that that was
very very weird yeah you're in that and
then you're out you've been in all these
great movies about small parts and gray
movies yeah but it's that's huge that's
really important that you haven't been
in a bunch of Big Time movies the tank
yeah yeah dude yeah the big yes hangover
yeah old school The Joker and the Joker
thing that was a huge [ __ ] deal
mostly but but I'm I you're acting I it
has always been well you're standing for
me has always been
you make it you always make it look so
easy that's how I feel about your
standout really don't make it look hard
make it look easy go ahead what were you
gonna say I remember one time yeah I
remember I did we did a set at The
Improv and you text me and he said
you're really funny man and I and I'm a
little depressed about my set right now
you just didn't feel good about your set
and you and you were like I just love
watching you and you're very
complimentary and then you were like I
need to get my [ __ ] together because you
you felt like you hadn't done well or
something it was so funny yeah I
remember going TJ you're one of the
funniest people in the world but I think
what's what's amazing about you it's
really hard to follow you really hard to
follow you because you have this very
controlled physicality so yeah I've
always thought of you as a physical
comedian but watching man tears I see
how you've really like pinpointed what
is what works and then you've sort of
parried it down and shaved away because
I think you started off as a really
physical Community yes and in man tears
you've got all the giraffe stuff with
the the eyelashes
you watch the whole beautiful eyelashes
I want all the eyelashes and but then
that's it yeah so then you'll go on and
you'll talk about you know and I'm not
gonna ruin the end of it but you'll go
on and you'll just you're just talking
and it's straight stand up and it's
about the writing and the words and then
when it makes sense again to Veer into
the physicality yeah yeah and I I love
that and then the ending of your special
of the entire special is a physical joke
it's a completely physical joke it's at
you know you you say what it is but it's
just the ending special it's just like
that's it yes the funniest [ __ ] thing
because you also I just hit myself on
the bed because you also I'm bleeding I
am uh you you also sort of trick the
audience and I love this [ __ ] this is my
favorite kind of [ __ ] you know what I
mean and you do like all three of us
love sort of [ __ ] with the audience
you guys [ __ ] with each other and it's
fun and the audience loves it because
they know that it's uh we're not like
it's all fun you know and so the thing
that I thought was so fascinating is you
really tricked the audience into
thinking that you hey man I've come to a
point kind of you know yeah I've got a
point I'll sit down up and just break it
down and talk about talk about you know
feelings and just something real finally
something real that's where I've gotten
to my stand-up yeah I'm gonna talk to
you about something real and really
expose myself and people are with you
and then you just totally [ __ ] them at
the end and it's so funny and it's like
it kind of makes fun of also what can be
really wrong with stand up which is
people like soap boxing it because you
already have a great joke I have a joke
right now that's like so hard to do but
it's similar to your Iceberg joke you
know and I think
um I'm flattered that you as a comic
watch the whole [ __ ] thing well I
didn't watch the whole thing no I don't
watch the whole thing I just skipped to
three different things and I was like
I'll just talk about it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no no I watched
all three because there's something
about that [ __ ] with the audience
kind of
um but you you did all the political
stuff you needed to do in that all you
really need to do is that Iceberg joke
yeah and it's great because the audience
is like what's his deal whose side is he
on kind of yes and you're like none of
them I'm not on everybody's side yeah I
don't want to draw I don't want to draw
but you know Alec Baldwin says something
I never forgot he said
um we go to the theater to laugh and cry
and I I you know making people laugh
throughout my career has never been you
know it's always been my thing right
we'll talk about this in a second we're
an old ring I got married
well it's
a rubber ring I can't wear it it's a
rubber I can't wear uh hard Rings it
just gets in the way I've never seen
Brian in a ring any any jewelry yeah
he's not rich
to show up with a bracelet yeah and I'm
wearing I see him messing with them like
I will I have an aura ring that's that's
right same thing yeah I don't like those
I don't like either I like because I
don't like it's like after you do it for
a few weeks and then some days you're
not gonna feel good you still gotta work
out or you still gotta do stand up when
it's like today's gonna be tough shut it
down it's like [ __ ] I got three shows
and yeah yeah right exactly like I don't
want to set my mental frame where I'm
like yeah I'm sluggish that's what the
whoop said my thing is because I'm brain
damaged I need like nine hours of sleep
ideally and it also has to be good sleep
so it really helps me with that I mean
the whoop is the same thing the same
thing but didn't you um you had didn't
you have to have surgery did you have
like really funny and kind of so funny
yeah it's like don't wear it anymore but
um you didn't you have have a surgery
check this out yeah I did like a
straight up brain all right oh that's
dope that's your wedding now yeah nice
that's pretty dope that's the band I
like that let's get I just got a tattoo
but he had kids it gets caught on [ __ ]
and all exactly yeah that's the problem
also if you lose it you you know yeah I
was saying about like this thing about
making like you go to the theater to
laugh yeah yeah and uh I gotta ran it in
here dude
just get all crazy that's got a lot of
caffeine by the way no yeah I felt it
just that how sick did I get when I
drank two of those whiskey and I take
nicotine yeah
I think that's pretty funny I was taking
nicotine say that instead of smoking
cigarettes hey I take nicotine oh really
yeah yeah anyway did you ever did you
ever smoke no yeah I didn't I don't like
but I smoked cloves that was something
that's going out but they're not
addictive yeah so it's really really
he's a walking Pharmacy he's got a lot
of stuff running through his body oh
yeah enjoying me while you can I'll be
uh I'm pregnant with three years yeah
that's it that's all yeah uh but you you
straight up had brain surgery right
Wikipedia yeah I had this thing called
Insurgent yeah I had this thing called
an AVM and it was
um
it's a malformation in your brain that
happens when you're in the womb and it
was about the size of a golf ball and
it's it's more fragile than the rest of
my brain
um and so they had to embolize it just
put glue around it and then take it out
so they took out a golf ball size of my
brain so I had 10 success rate what yeah
yeah that's right there's only yeah one
out of ten people die from this and so
they were like you know they go do you
wanna it's elective and I said well will
I still be funny after the surgery Jesus
and the guy's like what the doctors are
trolls yeah yeah right oh my God
maybe you will be funny finally you know
they're just hoping it makes you funnier
yeah that is what you love about
somebody right so yeah kind of I mean
you go straight in here so what was
weird was I didn't use this so what he
said was he goes well you know
um it's not I you don't really use that
part of your brain so I think you'll
still be funny but he part of him was
like oh my god oh [ __ ] yeah he said I
think so he said it's electric surgery
you don't have to get it I said well
what happens if I don't get it he's like
you'll probably die in your mid-30s what
and say well let's roll the dice see
what this is all about yeah did you
really say that yeah and so now and
always it's not selective I have a
um I have this I have Mania so that's
what I have to medicate because my brain
ostensibly has to work harder than all
of yours because it has less brain
matter and so that's created a lot of
problems where I've tried to medicate
that yeah that's my problem too really
no I think mine CT that's the nicotine
that's the nicotine that's all the Nick
in the Denver one yeah the Denver Water
uh and so that's what's created a lot of
problems for me is it made me very
successful because I would just do I
could do this and these five things that
I would just say I'm good at but but it
would also get when it veered over into
the and I was self-medicating for a long
time just all depressants drinking
nitrous oxide and oh wow yeah
oh yeah where's that handsome little boy
yeah and that's right anal sex yeah
right up and numbs things up and so I
and then now I do this thing called
cognitive remediation but I had a
misunderstanding with the federal
government it was because I had a manic
episode we have a manic episode you
believe everything is real that you're
thinking you believe that you've gotta
get ahead of it and even become more
manic is that like a drug too yeah you
could I had a psychotic split once and
it's so hack
it ends up being really hacked because
everything that they talk about happens
to you so you think the television is
talking to you for sure you think that
the government is watching you do you
remember feeling crazy the Chinese
government is looking through yeah it's
absolutely crazy
it's just it's a day to day yeah
you're talking about life yeah yeah
you're talking about it every day of the
week
um but so you know they kind of now I do
this cognitive remediation and it's
weird stuff like I never feel tired
so I think people there are other people
that are like that but I've never I
don't drink coffee really and so what I
have to do is I have to look in the
mirror and see this part of the
remediation and say do I have physical
signs of being tired if I do have I been
yawning do my eyes look this way and if
I do then I need to go to sleep it's
almost like you're super I feel tired as
a comic that's it I don't feel tired at
all and that's the thing so I could do
so many [ __ ] sets and that's why I
moved to New York because my dream
forever has been to be a Manhattan comic
and a big part of that is I just I can
do five set my record right now is eight
sets in one night mine was six that's
really impressive yeah no that's really
impressive because you've got to bounce
with six you got to figure out
um a road map yeah you gotta start up
town or you're gonna start I started the
comic strip
um yeah yeah then New York comedy club
then Boston Comedy Club then New York
comedy club down on 24th yeah yeah and
then uh [ __ ] and then uh no it was
Greenwich Village comedy
clubs and I did a couple of tests that
were like um like rebar yeah yeah just
book shows it'd be tough to do eight in
L.A you could do possible I've done my I
was gonna say five or four yeah you
could do that four you could do it maybe
I did do five but I don't you do five
you can mostly do three of them Factory
and yeah you just go up and you do
whatever but that was my thing is I just
wanted to like do sets two sets and so
now finally I am kind of more remediated
and that's really interesting too
because I don't feel the same high from
the Mania but it is nice to kind of be
able to say all right you know tonight
I'm not gonna do a set or this I think
now the good thing for me would be to go
and to get into bed and just close my
eyes and then I will fall asleep that'd
be tough to manage yeah it's very you
know it's very strange but at the same
time it's really tough to manage if
you're married to me I think that's I
was gonna ask your wife because she
didn't sign up for this right until you
got diagnosed she's like oh that makes
sense yeah exactly yes but I know her
from college
so we've known each other since we were
like 20. George Washington whatever
right yeah GW he really did went to
America he really really yes sir George
Washington really yeah Kate and I got
um
um scholarships and hers for hers was
for
um it was called the whip program which
I think is very ironic it's women in
power whip
she got a scholarship for the wet
program yeah
um women in power yeah women
entertaining TJ it's the web program and
so um and so it's really interesting
because we both got scholarships but
hers was for a essay that she did on uh
female genital mutilation
in exactly so it's really serious then
she got a scholarship into this program
mine just showed up and it was like like
you got a presidential academic
scholarship and I didn't apply for it
and I was like what the [ __ ] is this
about and I guess they just wanted to
bring their like test scores of people
coming in up and that was it because I
didn't have any recommendations for my
high school only two oh
teachers would know only two teachers
would give you recommendations everybody
else literally was like I can't write
you a good kid is that amazing yeah I
mean what a [ __ ] horrible thing to
say to a kid I don't believe in you yeah
I just I simply don't believe in you go
to the Drama teacher and see if they'll
draft something up and what was your
activation you got an academic so it was
academic because just because I scored
high on the SATs that's it they just
wanted to bring that up to be like
average scores eight six or whatever it
was really interesting to me because
when I watched you uh because I tested
really well well but when I watch you on
Silicon Valley or I watch you on I'm
watching like a really different Choice
like I'm watching a really good actor
who looks super trained because the the
character you play wait on on [ __ ] uh
Silicon Valley and any other thing
there's this you have this ability it's
like maybe the tempo of your voice and
you get away you can get away with
anything because you just have that
natural sound good just to change just
smoke and drag queen
last night Bell now Billy Joel yes you
can do that and just talk but there was
you were doing something very specific
on Silicon Valley the self-entitled
[ __ ] guy who's just clueless but
self-important yeah so insecure yeah
yeah but no I mean yes is that from is
that from is that from studying acting
in a class or is that yeah we trained
didn't you you were trained and yeah
okay right but that was for uh in Paris
but it was circus Arts that's what I was
learning Shakespeare well I did go to
British Academy of dramatic arts but
that was only for the week and it was
awesome it was just Shakespeare and so
it was just a Holier and like
restoration comedy but all of it was
Shakespeare and I just was like why am I
here but luckily there was a clown from
DC this guy Floyd King and
um I sort of saddled up to him and I was
like I'm a comedian I like to do comedy
but outside of that I minored in theater
but I didn't really learn that much the
whole thing was in high school I had
this incredible Drama teacher Melody
Duggan and she stand up was one of the
sophomore year you have to stand up no
other no other drama High School class
no and then improv and she would have us
improvise and sometimes she just didn't
want to do she just didn't want to work
that day so you say all right everybody
get up an improvise and it was you know
as we were talking about East High
School was like mostly Black and Latino
and dramas and he's the class so it's
hilarious it was like the nerdy white
kids right and then all these gangsters
like legit Crips yeah like like uh East
and bloods actually their bloods yeah
but they were Bloods
me and Capitol Hill so so yeah
the high school went through in Denver
East it's weird because they have really
good academics yeah it's in the heart of
downtown so there's like some kind of
Rich smart white kids who go there
because it's really good academics but
it's in the heart of downtown it's a
public school so it's like you're yeah
and you're getting like rough and you
get and you're good at sports
kids would be code for black and brown
no yes no but also yes but yeah yeah
but like one of my friends this guy will
Zimmerman who's a brilliant photographer
he he passed he died and he was one of
the roughneck white kids who was really
smart but he wasn't in the accelerated
classes but like you know they were
white because they're dealing weed or
they're just you know there was all of
that but there were also a lot of black
and Latino kids latinx
and they're absolutely yeah there's
there's so but they they're the smartest
of those kids were also in the
accelerated classes and so I was too
because there's a lot of AC classes
there yeah yeah exactly people are
taking AP class so here's the thing I
aced my uh AP Psychology exam so that
was an instance of like and no one no
one Aces it really
um but I was fascinated with psychology
that was my um that was my major but so
in these drama classes she would be like
improvise and all the gangsters were
like I'm not gonna get up there and be
like a bing bong oh I didn't expect
you'd be here well what about me cousin
ten oh cousin what there's not even my
tool shed yeah yeah yeah let's uh
I didn't think you'd come in while I was
sawing
and they all have guns in their car you
know that's sort of advice
it's like Dangerous Minds but with
really good teachers yeah yeah exactly
everyone's Michelle Pfeiffer and so uh
and so I kind of
um I was just improvising all the time
for hours because we have these block
periods so for three hours I would just
be on stage improvising I think that was
the whole thing and so what I do in
Silicon Valley all these things I really
improvise and I think the thing that a
lot of people did you improv provides a
lot in Silicon Valley yeah it's
completely oh my God but my judge is so
funny so I would do both of those but I
think what's Gangster what I relate to
is that show it was so big you're like
uh I'm gonna move on yeah everyone's
like what the [ __ ] you'll talk about us
most people like I can't believe he's
moving honestly yes and you know and you
know what I relate to something with
that so a lot of um I I talked to
Michael Bay yesterday never heard of him
and I haven't either and he called and I
was like Michael what I didn't even say
who I go Michael what call me when
you're what do you mean what the bay
what are you talking about water what
are you saying here Michael Lake and uh
Michael Pond he's yeah I would never
call that man Michael Pond
um but we were just talking about the
being a Maverick because I think he is a
genre and enter that guy like created a
genre Legend he's so he's totally
legendary and he's talking about
Maverick and that's you guys are both
Mavericks and that's just a word that
I've been thinking about and talking
about and you know talk about the media
just being like what would be clickbait
and destroy the true story they were
like oh TJ was crazy people were like oh
yeah I did I wanted to move on because I
was like I don't like doing things for
more than five years that's really true
and I got to the point and this is how
much I really care about the audience
um
I started being on autopilot yeah I
really noticed that I was showing up too
comfortable and I was I was just uh
sleepwalking through it and then people
will say like did you smoke weed on set
and stuff and no they give you fake weed
you know but I really thought I got to a
point where it's like I could be totally
stoned this entire time I mean I play a
stoner who's always high and I had
gotten into the Rhythm it was five years
because the pilot was so it's Four
Seasons five years and I could have just
gotten high and kind of that could be my
job and work right I never get tired so
it's like I can get high that could be
my job yeah I want you to click into a
character after that it's just you get
you get bored look at bored and also
you're doing a disservice to the
audience but but also because I like
this audience I want them to think and I
don't want them to be like oh man that
was such a funny show and TJ was great
but then in like episode five and six
they were really trying to like shoehorn
them in there I don't want that yeah
yeah and I I think through the level of
success that show was at for you to walk
around that time I think most people
like I can't believe he's walking away I
go oh I'm a fan now so that's what
Hollywood
once he was no longer on the show it's
like I'm a fan of that guy because I
like the show but then when you walk
away I'm like oh that's some gangster
it's true that's some Denver East High
[ __ ] exactly right that's some Aurora
[ __ ] yeah what's up dude uh so dark
knight
uh and he's in the Joker at all oh my
gosh
it becomes immediately
[Laughter]
[Music]
I forget to use the microphone
um it just shoots the top of Brian's
head yeah that's right that's it right
there
um and so golly now I feel like a
cameraman more than a podcast guest you
know he's almost there
um yeah so I got basically scored really
high you know I'm just testing SATs and
all that and then went to George
Washington University and that's where I
met Kade actually
and so it's weird I'm so lucky but she's
seen me from open she's been open mics
at one point she was like can you stop
doing shows on New Year's Eve and what
she meant was you ruined our New Year's
Eve every year by doing shows and so
then I was like yeah I'm not gonna do it
but she's seen the entire progression
she was there during Silicon Valley and
that's what HBO said HBO at Hollywood
was like why are you what why are you
leaving because the system doesn't work
that way yeah and you finally made this
Show's so successful and I I also had a
component of it that was like I was
doing film and I was doing stand-up
every night after so I do 14 hours you
know I mean you can be on the [ __ ]
set I shot schooled right next to you
guys on the Sony lot yeah so you guys
literally so that my my trailer was here
silicon Valley's trailer was right here
you guys were all over here yeah it was
we were right next to each other and I
would do he he knows I would be working
a six narrow day I would try I would
schedule so I I'd have an hour and a
half to run to Santa Monica do the
podcast and come back and I do it in my
my [ __ ] outfits depression and not
miss the pot because you'd come in
makeup God you did because you know yeah
it's good it's good it's absolutely good
but I because I was doing stand up
every single night and they had to move
stuff for me to do I also was like and I
had a psychotic break during that point
it's just as we were talking about
before and so they definitely were like
they gave me an out you know they gave
me this really funny way to leave the
show which is or like it's just an opium
den and that's where he stays forever so
I thought that was so funny but they
also were kind of like you know this is
hard so maybe do you want to do three
episodes out of ten or seven or what and
I was like no I think this is just such
a perfect time to leave it such a funny
way to leave
and the HBO was so sweet they just were
like oh that's good hey sure you really
want to do and I go yeah and I think
that Hollywood in general not HBO they
call you in general it's like
but don't you want to buy a boat yeah
and that's the mentality it's like
didn't you always want to be a TV actor
a TV star everybody wants that stand and
I was like no I want to be a stand-up
and also I don't want to buy a boat I
want to live in Manhattan with my wife
and do stand-up comedy and so that's
kind of the impetus behind leaving but
now I have this kind of weird situation
this haunting conversation do you do the
comedy zones yeah Florida so yeah
and I did Charlotte and this guy half
who like runs on love came to me he's
great and he came to me and we were
talking and he you know he's got all
this stuff going on and then I was like
you know I think the problem is that
people don't know that I'm a stand-up so
I'm trying to get more stand up online I
think it's special yes I think it's a
big part of it either that or I'm not a
great Santa but they kind of they you
know they know me as an actor and
they're coming to see me as an actor and
then after was like whoa he can actually
do stand-ups so I think I need to show
everybody that because it's the acting
it's the film and television that's
bringing them in the first place and he
was like and it always will be and I was
like
what and he goes that'll always be the
way the people will come to see you and
I thought it was so weird and I thought
okay he's talking about
um not this is existential stand-up
stuff he's talking about I will always
be more famous for film and television
and stand up which is true because I'm
that famous it's not a bad thing yeah
and you're a lot of people come and see
you because of the podcast but also
because you're filming television stuff
doing Goldbergs how many teachers that
sell three how about when you how about
when you had your school off of school
how many tickets before yeah but he was
doing shows like no I know Deadpool and
Silicone Valley so they're going to come
out yeah you were doing big [ __ ] and you
had yeah you had like standout roles but
then also but you've also had a bunch of
specials that you're special on Showtime
and all the specials you've released I
guess maybe because you're from Denver I
follow more closely I've always viewed
you the stand up so when you say but
you're also a comment yeah but when you
get those big roles to me I'm like oh
[ __ ] yeah it's a stand up you guys see
but you know nobody saw the HBO people
saw the HBO special but I was young I
think I hadn't done as much stand up it
was supposed to be really avant-garde I
don't think it connected but it was also
time is that the one where you drink the
water like exactly me and my brother
could not stop laughing it's so funny
but the reason it's out of nowhere yeah
the gerbils drink water like this he
goes and it's it's actually I'm in the
middle of this it doesn't make sense
everywhere but so that is so random and
it was so [ __ ]
because nobody would definitely it is
ridiculous because it's ridiculously
ridiculous it was absolutely ridiculous
he goes you guys it's out of nowhere
just because I've seen a dribble drink
water yeah she's like and and so the
rest of the show I love [ __ ] that's it's
the best yeah and so I think Comics that
might be the greatest bit of all time
[ __ ] like that more than anything yeah
but you're you're you're prone to doing
that you'll just Veer off and kind of
especially when you interact with the
crowd you're just very you are very that
and um and so I kind of
um you know I think the reason I did
dear Jonah which is my special that's
out on YouTube right now
um
just released it like end of September
and it's uh it just it ended up being so
perfect I was like in Nashville
Tennessee and I thought I mean you guys
know so the second show in Nashville is
essentially a bachelorette party and
they put a city in there right correct
somewhere inside
I saw I saw one of them I'm not wearing
any of you here's how Tennessee this is
right exactly I'm not trying to break up
any marriages with all these annoying
individuals there was one of those that
was being dragged by a tractor so it's
like how tennis how much are you leaning
into this and also the guy driving the
tractor looks so sad it was one of those
weird things where you look at a man and
he's just like how did it end he's like
I get a dude
slowly going to Kid Rock song
so we're so we're you know I'm there I
go okay the second show the first show
on Friday night wasn't great it was good
we didn't get it and the second show I
go look this might be a [ __ ] disaster
so if it is I'm just gonna rip with the
crowd we'll get that and then we'll put
it on social and he was like no no we
need we still need to just do the set
again I go I'm not I can't guarantee
that then I walk on stage and I start
doing the set and if the audience is
[ __ ] unbelievable they're so amazing
and you know and I was yeah and you do
know because you have that moment
especially in a special you're waiting
for the crowd you just wait and they're
right there and then this [ __ ] drunk
guy in the front row starts heckling me
and I'm like just don't don't just don't
pay attention to them yeah that's
exactly please please please don't just
forget that you're even here yeah and he
won't stop acting and he's he's the kind
of drunk we forgot there's other people
and so it's just me and him and he's
like he goes yeah yeah that's true yeah
well he's hilarious he's looking at
other people every punchline and I'm
like please that never happened that's
exactly right hey it was it was very
much like that kill him and so [ __ ]
kill him oh if you could like take him
so anyways so there I go I go
I'm not gonna kick this guy out let me
just talk to him so I make a joke I ask
him about his cargo pants
and he has the most elaborate
reason that he wears cargo Pockets even
though he's have anything inside but he
obviously just likes cargo pants and as
he says this it's immediately clear he
is not drunk at all oh he's
developmentally challenged he's what do
they call they somebody who's like
mentally divergent or something I was
talking about it with my my
neuropsychologist who I've worked on
stuff and he and she goes well now we
call them uh intellectually deficient
and I was like that's horrible yeah
that's really weird that's not like
that's your stop I'd rather call me Rita
yeah neurodivergent that's exactly what
it is so he's neurodivergent and it was
so bizarre yeah and everyone in the
audience was like what's going on
so much tension all the all at once the
entire room because he he's clear he was
you know like this and so then I go to
the I go
I want you guys to know that I am not
going to make fun of him at all and the
audience explodes they're like ah
because they all were like this is
weasel from Deadpool he insults Ryan
Reynolds in his face and all that stuff
this is Ehrlich from Silicon Valley
where he insults every single person so
they were waiting they're like is TJ
gonna be like
and I didn't at all of course and what I
said what I said was you know Brooke's
attention and I sort of said okay and I
complimented him and said I like to wear
things because they're comfortable also
and I don't need to carry things in them
all that and I was like okay now we're
gonna move on to the next thing but then
he interrupts again but I well hold on I
incorporate him into the show and then
slowly and this was really interesting
slowly I Incorporated him then I asked
him this part of the nose flute game
show and there's so slowly this show
becomes really about him and at the end
he's he has the funniest line in the
entire show and then at the end the
closer involves him and it's ridiculous
and so it was going to be called the
pandemic special and then after I looked
at an edit and I as soon as I got off
stage I was like I think that's the
special and then Kate and the director
Arnold Aldridge come in and they go
I think we're gonna pitch that that's
the special right and I was like that is
the special and so we renamed it from
the pandemic special to Dear Jonah
because dear Jonah the guy's name is
Jonah oh wow and it sort of became This
Love Letter to the sky that one it was
so way different than I thought I know I
thought you were saying so then after I
mean the boys wrapped them up in the
back no even more
guy that's so cool and it was so
interesting to yeah and so it's it's so
interesting to see it and you've got to
watch all the way through that is one of
the problems is that people now don't
watch all the way through I watched five
minutes Tick Tock and it's only 45
minutes it's not even an hour especially
yours is 50 38 I think yeah I did 30
minutes yeah yeah I met with Netflix
Amazon everyone and you know met with
the head people at Netflix and like we
know for a fact people stop don't matter
who it is they stopped watching after
what is that 20 minutes 28 minutes so
there you go with us Dave Chappelle
Kevin Hart Joe Rogan Bill Burr because
they know for a fact majority the
audience 28 minutes and I go then why am
I going to burn my hour yeah why would I
just give it 30. exactly
here's a pretty crazy like you're a
[ __ ] after that
I went and in three weeks like three
weeks later I filmed a completely
different special in Tampa this is
what's Gangster completely it was pretty
gangstering thing and it's really good
and I was thinking about doing both at
the same time but that wasn't gonna work
at all
um but you know so then it became this
kind of dear Jonah thing instead of the
pandemic special a lot of it's about the
pandemic because I was like I gotta burn
this because it's not gonna make sense
exactly and
um and that what was great about it is
that it captures two things about me one
I improvise all the time in my shows
it's basically a [ __ ] jam band
riffing crowd work but I was just
talking about the city I will talk about
the city for 20 minutes and I've seen
yourself I think that's your superpower
yeah I mean it's really an outlier
amongst other Headliners well I think
it's really really fun to do that but
you've got to have stuff online to get
people to be like so the special
perfectly shows that and then it
perfectly kind of shows
um that I'm like like not an [ __ ]
like it's so important for people to
know who I am and so dear Jonah really
shows people that because I like love
this guy slowly I'm like he's the best
part and Jonah's headlining him I think
it's outrageous you have to prove you're
not an [ __ ] anybody who knows you
knows you're not an [ __ ] I know but a
lot of people as long as I do knows that
welcome to the [ __ ] Club same thing
I don't get it I yeah I don't I never
understood here's one thing that I don't
pay attention to it so I've never
thought that of you at all but I'll get
the same thing too oh he's an [ __ ]
he's a bullying
also we we match a certain I don't even
interrupt you but I think this is really
true that we all match this demo this
demographic that people love to hate
right now and you guys even more so
because you're like Fighters I mean
you're like [ __ ] you are the thing
that so much of American culture right
now is like rewind a fighter I like that
let's hold on to that oh my God he's
always going like this one my hand are
crazy fast yeah you're so fast well you
had that was for a little while you had
that that was yeah I love that I love it
you know and um and but I never heard it
about you though I get it a lot I know
that but I just look like you guys more
than I look like a non-binary and you're
more famous and you're more sort of
cisgender yeah you're you're you've done
nothing I don't know here's here's the
thing important really seriously this
and I want to play something after this
you know all you've done is like try to
make people laugh right and pretty damn
good at it so if you were to tell you
the amount of laughs that you've created
like it literally dedicated the past 20
years to just making people laugh this
and that's like literally all I think
about is how to make people laugh I quit
fighting and make people laugh
should be the ultimate proof did you see
[ __ ] um
Krista Stefano talking to Bert Kreischer
no about what
did you see that on his Instagram yes
I'll check it out did you see that [ __ ]
do you know Chris he's in watch this
he's in Staten Island oh yeah he's
hilarious too yeah I like his specialist
I watch his oh so let me preface this
with how much
here here hold on if it's on his
Instagram he can just bring it up here B
um Chris why is it here I'm not showing
up I'm obsessed I think it's is he
Shadow band no hold on no there it is no
he should be verified
so so like the amount of travel you have
to do as a comic that is weird just
Google it the amount of travel you do as
a comic and if you have kids you know
your your kids don't see you as much as
you'd like them to yeah listen uh this I
saw this this morning I was like man I
I've never talked about this but it's
about what you'll see I've never spoken
about this I've never spoken about like
how in some ways difficult being on the
road it's all the time I'm excited this
is an exclusive yeah I'm glad to be on
this particular episode I talked to
Chrissy D
um
I love this now it's not on his I talked
to Chris he's not which one is not I
just oh this is Mr Jason okay got it
guys I talked to Chrissy D probably a
month or two ago because he was at you
know he has three kids now he's so funny
but he was asking how I navigate being a
dad he's like you're such a good dad and
I said my tour go go watch this first
yeah
but you have that
hey B let's take a little break from
chatting TJ Miller's ear off you'll
notice from Denver now you do buddy now
you do now the one thing TJ will allude
to this I think maybe we talked about
already he he doesn't know when to sleep
yeah I can't wait to get sleep because I
have a helix match well because now let
me explain something to you please take
a quiz that people sleep differently
some people are hot sleepers
you you Helix mattresses they've got 14
unique mattresses wow they have a
collection of luxury models they got a
mattress for Big and Tall they got they
got ones just for kids okay so and so
you find out what mattress works best
for your body because you only spend
more than a third of your life in bed
and it's the most important thing you
can do for your health all right they
will ship a personalized mattress
straight to your door free of charge you
sleep on it for 100 nights risk-free
it's a risk-free 100 nights they'll take
it yeah
every bet I have in my house is Helix
all right and all I did I took the Sleep
quiz they matched me with the perfect
mattress for my thick ass it's a firm
bed which I need and I sleep on my side
they got me covered all right not only
is this the best mattress I've ever
slept on but it was set up fast and easy
Helix mattress are delivered in a box
straight to your door for free right and
they come with a 10 to 15 year warranty
so if you're ready to get the best night
of your sleep all you got to do is go to
Helix all right go to helixsleep.com
fighter and you get 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for all the
viewers and listening to fight on the
kids helixsleep.com fighter come on with
Helix better sleep starts now just watch
okay sorry
one of my daughter's swim meets yeah I
just made
sick a lot of money and I'm like but I I
watched I've been watching my daughter's
life on my phone what am I doing like
she's never gonna be six again you know
and I missed like tons of her life yeah
I I make this money but I'm like I've
watched my kids life do a [ __ ] face
time and I'm the only dad that has been
in her swimming tour
it just like killed me yeah how do you
do it because something doesn't do it
how do I [ __ ] do it
I can't tell you it gets back
[Music]
dude
bro I was like I haven't no and I'll
talk about go ahead and go ahead sorry
nobody nobody talks about that you know
and people don't and if you have kids
that speaks so clearly to you and I so I
do a podcast called cashing in with TJ
Miller I heard you have to say things
three times so cashing in with CJ Miller
is me and cash Levy he has an interview
show he has a tough time getting guests
so I've been the only guest on it in
seven years and uh it's super [ __ ]
fun it's great it's great there it is
right there cashing a TJ Miller I see a
comic yes a very funny comedian but he
has two kids he has two sons yeah and he
really believes in having kids he said
there's only two things that you
um never regret jumping off a rope swing
into a lake and having kids he's right
and he really really he is right about
that right and so he really says the
same thing which he really talks about
you know everything for these kids is on
the weekends and that's the only time
you can work and so and of course people
do dude you know day weekday gigs but
it's really really and so he says that's
why I take the 6 a.m flight and I get up
at 4am because I want to be there for
every moment that I can and I know
Jason Bateman is amazing father amazing
father but he's talked about
um filmmaking like war that you go to
war you're not going to bring your kids
to war right you're not going to see
your wife and wife on tour you can't do
it so
um I have four children that are frozen
I have four sort of human embryo
children that are all Frozen three
daughters one boy miles and Alice and
two ones that'll die
or be born of some other woman's womb
and uh so weird thing to say and I've
recorded forever so just forever just 20
years what did happen that your kids he
was weird about unborn children and so
um you know I really think that Kate and
I can say this because she'll never
watch this I could be honest about it
um Kate is an incredibly talented uh in
installation artist which means she
would come in here and the entire space
would become something different
installation it sounds like it got
clipped in I mean everybody jumped over
somebody dubbed you over she's a really
delicious yeah I'd say she's a really
talented solution
um but she's hired she's she's awesome
and her career was [ __ ] by the
pandemic so was ours so it was everybody
who did the things that make life worth
living restaurants comedy all of it all
that [ __ ] and so she's amazing yeah yeah
right exactly but
I love you type so fast you don't type
anything
girl hola foreign
look she does really really amazing
stuff like click that cake or anything
just the yeah and so but if you go to
like yeah the Our Place Broken yeah no
go to one yeah go to our couple play I
can't even pronounce
um and so she does this crazy [ __ ]
that's you know just amazing bizarre
yeah yeah and so she really wants to do
that and she's doing really well in it
and I have to travel quite a bit every
weekend not every weekend but I could
not right now I couldn't do two or three
weekends a month that's just and I don't
want to because I want to do stand-up I
want to be getting better at standings I
want to be a great stand-up yeah and I
want to perform during the week
sometimes too and I think that she has
really
kind of I guess I don't know necessarily
but I think she's kind of like unless
you can do that
then I don't know if we can have kids
yeah unless you can fully commit to
being a pop unless you and that you can
have the time to do it you know that's
so cool look at that her work oh yeah
she's crazy
just the craziest is that a person or is
that a no it's a mannequin and that's
something that she knows it's so it's
like you know I think that that's the
problem is you know and what cash has
said is you know that it is two things
it's the greatest job in the world yes
it's there is nothing better than you
being on stage it's just you I'll do it
until I die and yes and you and you're
making hundreds and hundreds thousands
of people laugh and
it's also going to completely [ __ ] up
your ability to be a father like other
fathers correct I said to Chris though
and they're they're not they're mutually
exclusive but I text Chris today I said
you know my dad was always welcome today
yeah my dad was always gone but I love
my dad
and what I knew is that like part of it
is also this remember you know yes Chris
isn't seeing his daughter but she's
going to be proud of him there's a lot
about him like that dude that dude he's
such a good person we're also good a
small fraternity of people who can make
anybody laugh anywhere at any time
that's very hard to do for an hour try
that and so yeah there's a headliner no
one and so that's rare air and it it
does take all of you and it does take
the weekend and so there's a lot your
kids are proud it takes not only the
weekend during the week you know people
don't know people you don't see it I'm
doing four to six nights a week so I put
my kids to bed they don't know Dad's
working at night they wake up at 5 30 6
a.m before you can be there for them
during the day yeah you have different
one-year accounts different types of
time than other fathers but I just feel
so strongly about what you just said and
I also one joke that I was going to tell
your audience in particular is when you
save fraternity you mean a Brotherhood
but so much of America is like oh
another frat boy huh interesting so it's
just ridiculous but you are a part of a
group of people who really went out for
their dreams and made it happen and
that's the type that's the type of role
model you want to be not the guy that's
there every week and yelling uh to add
some embarrassing comes to every game
and he's always telling me what to do
and how he can be better you don't want
to be someone no Daniel took any chances
he was a dentist we did really well as a
dentist and I never wanted to work on me
it was so embarrassing like what is how
is that guy a better again role model so
much of what your kids should be is the
best parts of you yeah and then their
own thing it's something that's not you
at all setting a great example but
loving your kids is a huge part of it
and there's a lot of fathers right and I
really believe this there's a lot of
dads out there that really are like
goddamn it didn't really work out for me
so I'm gonna push push push my son to be
the thing that I and then also hate on
the others that do pursue their dreams
it's called Reddit yes called Reddit
it's called a threat about you I I
really really feel like you you want to
be and none of us the three of us will
never be like God I hate my job never
you can say I hate the travel which I
don't say but maybe one day I feel so
lucky to be able to do it yeah
I just feel so lucky and you've been
there for 70 years if I can really
really if I can really really uh just
have a huge compliment party right now
just because I know him uh much more
than I know you yes
um we're from you've always been
you know what I'll do in the middle I
don't give up
but you have always been a role model to
me as a comic I've always looked up to
you because of your philosophy I've said
and people have stolen this and put it
on their HBO show but I have said from
the beginning I have said from the
beginning that comedians are the
philosophers that we have now and that's
why it's so dangerous to not let us
speak frankly because we're able to
package a philosophy and give it to
people in a palatable way it's not a
[ __ ] Ted talk but it can be just as
brilliant and insightful and effective
absolutely right and then people will
listen to it and walk away like but
you've always been that to me and then
on top of that so grateful and so happy
for other people's success and so happy
for your own success but in a way where
you're like look if I can do it you
can't always good to younger comedians
but [ __ ] that a little bit because they
can't take in everything always good to
the people that have been doing it
longer than you but most importantly to
your peer group you have always said to
everybody in your peer group I'm happy
for your success I think what you're
doing is amazing and if you have any
questions for me or think that I can add
anything to your experience of doing
stand up know that I am here and I'm
always available and that is such an
incredible thing because so many Comics
can't do that right and the reason they
can't is because they're not as
self-assured they're not as happy about
you the only other person that I know
that's really like you except for
Brennan is Cash Cash Levy has a way that
he is like I'm the luckiest person in
the face of the planet to do this I have
to get back and what I have to sacrifice
for it is this and just even hearing you
say I'm I'm kissing the kids good night
and then I'm [ __ ] doing a set because
that's what it has to be and also I
think that the three of us I feel very
fortunate for this we are not motivated
by ourselves there's just nothing about
the three of us that is like man I
[ __ ] oh yeah it's about me dude these
people love me where that's only present
because you go God I'm so lucky that I
can do a thing that makes them be like
and it's so bizarre because a lot of
comics that talk [ __ ] or not even woke
just like think they know the way to do
it because they're doing the best and
people don't uh appreciate what they're
doing they just don't have as much to
offer as somebody that's really on stage
and there's altruism they we want people
and so because of that I think we are
the absolute luckiest I like rare air
and we also are going to be good Fathers
good friends good husbands rubber ring
and I gotta break I'm being too serious
I got a rubber race
I'm quitting stand up after this because
I've arrived I've done it I've done it
no yeah and you have done it but you
also have you been doing it though
that's the thing nobody gives Brian
credit Brian gave me my start right like
you can find the kid live but I wouldn't
say everybody gives Brian credit anybody
that knows you knows exactly how good
you are how hard you work why you do it
and that you're an all-around amazing
dude and that's that's your real that's
who you really are thank you that's why
I married a 22 year old
33 years old that's what she tells
people to get into movies
there you go
his hair just Rose a little bit on that
one it did right and I am not going to
go over and move the camera that was a
[ __ ] disaster disaster
how funny was that video I made for you
for them oh my God that was [ __ ]
funny man did you play that kid I'm
playing that you play that video it was
so funny we were laughing sorry because
I got married I was getting married
I never saw the shirt in my life he's
just Brian's never got his shoes
man so the days get married I send Brian
this video oh so it's me and the glasses
so funny man that's the other thing that
I think comes across with you yeah yeah
let's watch this
okay
I know you get married Chris you
probably didn't know this my friend
Brian's getting married today it's a big
deal I couldn't sleep last night I was
thinking
she married my friend for the right
reasons
65 years old
she married you for your merch money
think about it and that's that that new
I'm trying new merch dude that official
Pride count merch I mean dude I don't
know it just smells fishy that merch
just trying to pop
I'm sure you haven't walked down the
aisle yet and it's just something to
consider
your merch Monday yeah
she's just manual for your official
broadcast
Cowell saying dude think about it she's
young hot
69 years old I don't know it just smells
fishy you know something to consider
dude I don't certain I know you get
married today but
I need her per second wedding day today
we're laughing so hard yeah amazing but
I think one of the things about you is
that well not in this video actually
just negated the thing I was gonna be
saying but you come across as a guy
whose values are in line
and you know with Brian with everybody
that we love
um Ben askren's a really nice dude too
yeah I'm in Milwaukee and yeah and I did
his podcast he's a really good deal but
anyway so
um I think that comes across from you
too and so I just think it's hard to be
a father in that capacity but you're a
much better father like you're saying
than if you in kind of a better father
than if you were still fighting oh 100
yeah so that's also a different thing
it's stressful and then your kid is kind
of like so my dad beats the [ __ ] out of
people for a living that's just a hard
thing to explain it's a tough gig and I
would assume I don't know the same with
comedy like when you go in as uh you
know when you go into when you're going
to on tour you can't have your family
you know how it is like my girl like oh
you're in New York and Boston like yes I
could be in Iraq it's all the same yeah
I'm just working that's right I'm right
it's like War yeah yeah in fight Camp
it's like eight weeks and then you have
the little ones around they're waking up
early there's no way you could do it man
there's no way to be president yeah it's
and that's such a bummer but it's guys
do it pro sports you do have to be
completely about yourself right I mean
Tom Brady's getting a divorce because of
it yeah yeah and that's a lot of people
have been talking about that and I think
cash and I talked about on the podcast
and it is
he has this like feeling that no one
else has which is being the best at
something yeah absolutely he doesn't
want to leave and when he said I'm
leaving she was like okay I've held out
for this long and he's like I'm gonna go
back and do more I think she's I
understand but she's a woman and she's
like I'm not gonna [ __ ] do this she's
like enough and Kate broke up with me
because I was in Chicago doing stand-up
and I said I was going to move to New
York and I said just wait for me after
six months then after a year she's like
when are you moving up here I was like I
just need a little bit longer here and
then at two years she was like are you
moving up here and I was like I need a
little bit more time here she's like
well that's it so she broke up with me
and it was so [ __ ] up and yeah [ __ ]
up I'm I'm pissed off at her she she can
honestly she doesn't watch so she can go
[ __ ] herself right Outdoors not even in
the apartment
and uh right Outdoors yeah direct
directions it's a nice day we should
hope so maybe she should do it in
February
um but I you know I think that it's just
such a
I don't know man I mean grind yeah it's
such a grind but I think that she she
now wants to do that for her work and I
kind of joking was like well you know we
kind of want to have kids and so it took
a really big conversation where she was
like you know I need more time and she
totally [ __ ] me because I was like oh
I did that to you didn't I but how old
are you how old are you
41. okay so yeah you're two years older
than me and then she's 41 too yeah yeah
it's kind of time but I think Hillary's
having twins yeah and she's been in her
late late 60s early early 80s yeah 74
years old
yeah and so you know there's all of that
also but I think what is weird is you
have to understand the woman's
perspective of I'm kind of a full-time
mom 60 of the time or whatever yeah or
40 of the time so that could be that can
be frustrating I was watching that
[ __ ] uh documentary with uh uh the
the [ __ ] up news.com sad truth behind
Stars pregnancy but that should be all
you need to understand that it's all
[ __ ]
you got to get such a bummer yeah it's a
bummer online uh like promotes
negativity like because if someone says
if they tweet out or they post on
Instagram TJ Miller best special I've
ever seen yeah three likes yeah because
the algorithm doesn't pick that up now
someone says yeah it's the [ __ ] worst
70 retweets yeah algorithm's like yeah I
get them it's like what the [ __ ] are we
doing did you see did you see the redeem
team on Netflix the story about the
Olympic team when they brought Kobe in
when it was LeBron James it was Carmelo
Anthony it was uh uh the [ __ ] is his
name
and they were they they lost they they
lost a bunch and then this was the
Olympics and stuff and they talk about
[ __ ] Kobe Bryant with Paul Gasol you
talking about the clip I sent you yeah
but I'm talking about I saw the
documentary oh the whole thing yeah and
they talk about Kobe Bryant and how they
all were training and practicing and
then they all went out one night let's
go out man we're in Vegas let's [ __ ]
go out yeah but why not do man look at
those big dig four in the morning
am I right yeah 4 30. wrong no you're
not wrong he's not wrong no do this four
in the morning uh 4 30 in the morning
they come they're coming [ __ ] back
into the hotel and Kobe Bryant is
sweaty he just finished lifting weights
and now he was going to the gym they're
like what are you doing and the amount
of the amount he would train I don't
know how much time he had at all for his
kids you would know more about that if I
don't know anything yeah I don't know
you're talking about complete you know
completely they they were like nobody
was like that nobody was like that
[ __ ] and then all that all of a
sudden they try to start coming down and
meeting him at five four Thirty in the
morning and Carmen I think it's like
it's just too early it's too [ __ ]
early yeah I can't do it man yeah I
remember uh everybody leaves and he
keeps throwing yeah he throws never went
out and never hung out with anybody he
would always sit separate recluse never
would [ __ ] hang with them but they
all respected them because I mean but I
remember when I was first I like being
on the court with him yeah but also I
remember my first headline I ran to
Kevin Nealon at I forget what airport
maybe like Chicago airport or whatever
Kevin Elin I was it was eight years ago
seven years ago Kevin Neal and we were
talking he was like because we met at
Adam Sandler's party not to name
government service party and uh he was
like oh what gig you were doing I was
like I was doing Schaumburg improv
whatever he's like oh cool and he's like
you have more dates coming up like every
weekend man he goes all right you have
kids right or you have one boy right now
he goes don't tour as much say take for
me do not tour as much well you've read
it for the rest of your life I was like
okay wow I regret it I regret it yeah
I miss my daughter's birthdays over and
over again I regret all of it yeah I've
never missed a birthday but I did
yeah but that's here's the thing man
that's and I understand you come become
emotional looking at this and I don't
have real kids I like living children
that [ __ ] got me my children are
suspended in time but Frozen what I
think though is that it's so hard to
Divorce Yourself
from
the reality of that it's other people's
values that a birthday is
society's special moment and the kid
absolutely of course but if you think
long game then they're not gonna care
about missing a birthday if you have
both been there for them all that you
could and also that you explain to them
Kate kind of she's diverged from this a
little bit but one of the things that I
loved about her was that
the anniversary excuse me the
anniversary I need more rain I gotta
rain this yeah get rain get rain get
rain down here oh it's terrible and so
and so what um what I think is I loved
about her is she wouldn't really do the
whole like you forgot my anniversary one
time we both forgot the anniversary and
then we were like you know what let's do
something really fun we we should
celebrate this and I think that she is
good about us saying like well you know
what I'm gonna miss your birthday but
let's plan this and do it another and so
I think you have to
help kids understand that I remember my
girl there's a lot of peer pressure in
Boston turned like two I was on the road
and I was like he's my son's name is
Boston and we turned two she wanted to
throw the party on a Saturday I was like
in San Antonio whatever I'm like at
least two throw the party on Sunday he
has no [ __ ] clue yeah he doesn't I'll
take a 5 a.m flight and you'll be back
on Sunday just throw it Sunday for God's
sakes and that that was a nail guy no
she did it yeah yeah I think that's the
reason and then you know teach the kids
early that that is the deal can I ask
you a question as a fighter yeah eight
inches
that's how long your ears are yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
talked about this for a second but how
do you feel about that your ears you
know that you're fighting and that
you're you've been hitting the face so
many times wait about my ears yeah ears
come from Jiu Jitsu wrestling yeah
that's what I'm saying but it's like a
badge of honor so this yeah that's this
exactly it's a bachelor yeah I knew it
yep he earned him so you got to earn
them it's like a you know it's a badge
of honor and I remember when I first
came to Hollywood when I retired from
fighting I did this pilot on E and it
was like with all these big names and
Alyssa Milano all these huge names and
they're like you're so good this is
going to get green lit and we're gonna
order 48 episodes oh my God I'm balling
here we go of course so I'm waiting for
it waiting for it four months goes by
and I'm hit my manager this low level
man you know I'm like dude where are we
at where he's like we'll find when I
hear something I [ __ ] tell you dude
yeah yeah finally he calls me four
months later he goes that's good news
and bad news man but I heard from me I'm
like here we go baby I'm gonna be so
[ __ ] it's gonna be sick he goes okay
so the show's not getting like that for
whatever reason I get picked up he goes
That's the bad news the good news is
have you seen botched you know with the
like the doctors he goes yeah yeah
they're big fans they want to fix your
hair it's for free I was like that is
not I'll get kicked out of the MMA
Community man they can't fix my ears
yeah he's like I think it'd be better
it's kind of a distraction on stage your
ears I'm like who the [ __ ] tearing my
ears he said I'm just telling you may be
on the episode what's this this is what
kind of Imagine Dragons you could be on
the episode The Fish your ears you can
promote your dates
I was like oh no you have no idea how
this works yeah yeah what are you
talking about yeah I was like this is a
terrible idea well that's I was always
interested in that because my ear does
look like a tortellini but yeah no but
here's the thing though I always
wondered like because it is kind of a
badge of honor because if you walk in
somewhere and you have kind of the
cauliflower air you know that's [ __ ]
nobody's gonna [ __ ] with no because that
guy has not boxed a little bit or been
done some MMA
it is yeah
training for two weeks and your ears
blow up like this like that guy's
putting some he's gotten hit in the face
with the [ __ ] with somebody's foot
with someone's leg at least yeah how
many years did you not even this it's
leg time you're talking legs
oh [ __ ] uh
2006 to you know so you probably 14
years oh wow that long yeah black belt
yeah and so do you when you fought were
you very methodical actually this is
probably you guys have talked about this
um were you very like methodical and
looking and think about the technique
and stuff terrifying or did you no no
butterfly really terrified
and so was it like I gotta get out of
this situation kind of yeah as soon as I
could get out of get out and that's
because I was fighting I remember I was
fighting Andre arlovsky as I was like
this so [ __ ] I was like the co-main
event in Vancouver but me and Brian
started the podcast before that when I
moved to LA so me and Brian were doing
fine with the kid and I'd walk through
the airport and people like you're
hilarious dude and I remember TSA was
said uh the TSA guy goes oh were you in
Vancouver dude are you doing a stand up
here I was like that's awesome I was
like do you not see the Billboards I'm
fighting Andre or lavsky dude for the
UFC and not in my head I'm like oh [ __ ]
I'm getting traction here from what I've
always wanted it's dude you should have
seen how terrifying it is though he
would have to fight another monster who
was 265 pounds if you make one [ __ ]
mistake in that ring one mistake you go
you go to sleep because it's not like
being a 155 pounder your head's the same
size those guys they jab you the right
way
you I talked to it
everywhere I have tiny ears they're so
small you can't even hear people making
fun of them but it was the training that
they would have to do they so he would
get in the ring with Giants and they'd
be swinging for the fences so you're in
the ring and you know they wear that
headgear it does nothing you know that
yeah all does stop you from getting
caught does nothing and then you have
these gloves and they they he would have
to be in there with somebody he didn't
know who was a monster kickboxer yeah
and they would just go I brought Brian
again I had Brian come to drive with me
so are you you know how to fight though
yes well so he can but you could kick
somebody's ass and I could also but I
would never are you from Denver East you
know how to fight yeah I do but it very
softly but I I remember we won't find
Bloods I'll fight a crap
comic I'll keep you busy yeah exactly
yeah
um but I remember when I was fighting
like crocop who's former world champion
I remember I was like this is the worst
gig in the world and then when I did the
interview and I beat him I get The
Knockout of the night I beat him and I
did an interview and then I categize was
horrible I'm terrified I don't want to
do this and they're like God God no talk
about how yeah
no no I hated this so I looked up to
that guy he got knocked out dude oh good
lord
um good Lord what a strange pair of
shorts uh so I um I'm friends with Gina
Carano because she was in the first
Deadpool she's great and she's amazing
and I asked her I said how did you go
undefeated and she was like just rage
just pure unadulterated rage I'm the
opposite and so that's what I was gonna
ask absolutely because she said that
really was and Ben askren was different
he kind of was like I come from
wrestling I had to sort of incorporate
that into the thing and that's I think
why he had a tough time
in that boxing gig because he was
stripped of half of his skill sets no
completely never even worked he was
really
yeah Mikey seems like really upset about
that and he he was and I said I didn't I
never saw that and he was like oh good
but I was like that has so much to do
with
yeah you're taking away but I remember
my coaches like even in training when I
was ranked top 10 in the world my kids
were like you gotta get mean or man I
was like I don't that's not what I do I
saw that in practice okay literally I
can't I was like I can't do like you
have to get meaner in order to be a
world champion like then this ain't for
me man I remember I got ranked top 10 my
coaches threw me like a party I walked
in the gym like top 10 in the world in
my head I'm like oh [ __ ] dude that means
I gotta fight nine eight seven six five
four and you're when you lose there's so
much more to lose on a macro scale yes
you know physically your health yeah 100
it's also so embarrassing so like yeah
if I have a set tonight at The Improv I
bomb all good I'll do another set at the
store yeah
no so it's like when I bump you're like
oh man that didn't go well yeah all good
I'll go I'll go redeem myself tomorrow
fighting and say it knocked out I got
six months to think about it and and
then I gotta get the backlash online
play that high I saw him one time when I
went to pick him up after
the arlovsky loss I think and the Rogan
thing
I have a black guy and I no hold on this
is off Main Street in Venice but we're
we're at uh groundwork's coffee
Brian goes meet me for coffee yeah he
trained so hard I was with him the whole
time he trained so [ __ ] hard and
Travis Brown comes in and Brendan just
didn't want to fight and long story
short on top just hitting [ __ ]
Brandon they call it off it's done and
he goes like this he I come over to him
as he gets out of the cage and he goes I
tried I go it's okay it's okay because I
tried I go it's okay and you go and I
see you and I go I'm picking you up at
it's the next day two days later no it
was after yeah it was it was actually
Court broken yeah before writing you
just you're just lowest point of your
life and I remember I took a picture of
you and I have the picture it's
hilarious black guy I have it on my I'm
in a tank top
I'm gonna take this picture
because this is the lowest part of your
life it's very important
and we had it and it was just like well
here's the we're in the valley sometimes
you're at the top of the mountain other
times you gotta get to the valley but I
was like in one mountain is the the what
the beginning of the next Mountain first
I love that it's true it's anything to
be able to be like is you know this was
you're gonna have a false Summit after
this you know you've seen Rocky right
yeah here's the thing you're in a stream
and you want to get to a Michael Pond or
Michael Blake and then you climb the
mountain and then the fall Summit was
just oh I guess there's another Valley
so you're gonna do that and then you're
gonna be on the planes for a while
you're gonna be the same straight into
the plane for a little bit and then you
go Valley again is there any other way
please is there any other way in life is
there any other way than to eat dicks
most of the time especially here's when
you everybody here has been in these
situations and thank God that you're
gonna say everybody here is eating dicks
everybody here is eating they're all
eating dicks oh everyone here has an
addiction their mouth let's be honest
every one of us here at least has been
in a row boat in the middle of the ocean
with no land in sight no paddle that
that's that's the nature of real chaos
where you're like I'm in the middle of a
robo and I don't know I can't see land
and I don't I don't I actually don't
think I'm gonna make a bag I actually
have no strength in my arms to paddle
you know and I think that again just to
go to Dear Jonah it's like that stand-up
special I was sort of like well you got
to say it three times uh that Santa's
special I was just like God please let
this go amazing because I financed it
myself and I was gonna Finance the
second one and I was like please please
please it's a different animal when you
forget about yourself and I was like
please let this go well and so many
things had gone bad
that when it went amazingly well it was
just so great and I remember Kate and I
she was there for that special and I
remember
I we sort of finished the second to
Friday we had this thing with Jonah I
was like this is it and we just went
back
to I'd ran a penthouse because I was
like we're not gonna finish this thing
and then go into like a shitty hotel
rooms it's actually both reflect a
little and so we got that and we just
went back to this [ __ ] room and just
partied we just [ __ ] yes 100 that's my
favorite way to party it's just her and
me because she's we're not just in
college so when it's when we're ready
when it's appropriate she knows when
time comes it is it gets messy but
that's possible yeah it is bananas and
so we just did that and we kept saying
each other we're like we needed this
like this is so awesome that this
happened it's real it's Kate kept me
like it shows the shape of your heart
and I didn't want to be like just shut
that's [ __ ] weird so I just was like
that's awesome that's a really great
expression give me the whiskey now and
and so but when it's those things right
then you love them so much more there's
so much more celebratory smelling the
Roses
when you go and you have the worst
[ __ ] stuff to me when that's
happening and I'm still like
wait a second
I'm a stand-up comic people are so nice
to me in New York I'll walk down the
street and somebody like I love you man
I'll be like I like your shirt and
that's great and I'm married to this
like homie from college who happens to
be banging it's just a really good
looking lady where when we walk down the
street people are like he must be rich
you know or something he's got an eight
inch or somewhere in there yeah or he's
blackmailer yeah
did she work for him because he worked
for her
um and when you can be at those really
low points and still be able to be like
God damn I got some great friends and
then you know your life is great correct
and when it gets those really high
points then you can really really get
into them and so I think that's a big
part of it have you noticed that people
have been saying correct more
I don't know because you guys both just
said correct I said I've been saying
that in a long time I believe that
because you make fun of your age
but I am concerned that no one says
right anymore I think it's really weird
and it's been happening everywhere and I
bring it up and no one is paying
attention
I feel like it's like a type I think
it's the misinformation on all the
social media correct correct all right
it's weird to say it but it feels like a
Twilight Zone thing works
I'm not it's a New York thing like me
and my friends in New York he's always
said a long time ago if you said
something like well but he'll also punch
you in the face you know if it's
something you go correct you know but
that's funny what we're doing is we're
correcting yeah what I do I use it when
I'm when you're correcting like and may
need I remind you right you can [ __ ]
around with them but you pull his tail
for long enough oh really pull your head
off yeah well that's correct yeah yeah
correct but see that's the perfect way
so are you so are you you're you're okay
you look better correct correct which
way are you supposed to turn left or
correct
it's always a reminder good guy [ __ ]
great guy you [ __ ] with him kill your
family correct I think that's the right
way
everyone stop one day everyone stops
saying right or yes yes it's just
correct correct right is right is the
lazy kind of like I'm listening to you
and I'm I'm letting you know I'm
listening to you but when you'd say
Miami has the best looking women on the
planet and then if I say that is correct
sir if you say that I say you are
married
and I say thank you correct yes correct
and she'll beat your [ __ ] ass yeah
correct but also if you say Miami has
the best looking women I go right that
sounds like I'm doubting it right right
there you go right you're right yeah
that was awesome well no there's an
argument when you go like this you go
yeah yeah but you know how do you do
right I think you tell me what are we
doing has that Miami has the best
looking women I usually go oh
this is how you come that's it no that's
how I say correct when I come I go
correct correct
correct are you erect correct correct
correct correct uh no we've covered a
lot of grounds see that's it but I think
is that correct we got emotional
emotional I hope that people uh make it
all the way through just like Dear John
I'm hoping people watch all the way
through they will because the ending is
so out I can't wait amazing yeah I'm
excited for you guys to see it no you're
you're my chance of man tears I don't
know you never know the front runner for
uh old Denver comedians man I've been a
fan for a hot second I'm hoping well I
love that you're from Denver isn't it
weird how and I'd like to exclude you
from this please do okay incorrect
um it is weird how people from Colorado
specifically Denver people in Colorado I
I get along with all of them oh yeah I
really haven't met a lot of people and I
think it's because if you grew up in
Colorado the weather is so amazing yep
that you're happy you're just
automatically kind of as more days
and did you start at The Comedy Works no
and she would never really work me I
started in Chicago she would never
really work me and then she still kind
of didn't and then I got to a point I
was like I'm just gonna do the gothic
theater and because I'm a denverite they
really really
um I have a very strong Denver following
and then I have a small group of people
in Denver that feel very strongly about
me yes and so I am kind of controversial
there but everyone I know everybody's
like yeah I mean isn't it weird it's
it's a Colorado thing and everybody I've
met a couple people from Colorado even
people that live there and they're
um they're just cool they're nice really
get along with them they're nice where
where are you from originally Saudi
Arabia Philippines
the Philippines
but you're New York New York but Wendy
at Comedy Works she wouldn't pass me
forever and I was like you know I grew
up you know idolizing that place you I I
told my agent I'm like yeah get me in
there I love Wendy so then finally shoes
I I'll give them a Wednesday so I did a
Wednesday she watched the show and then
the following year she after me a
weekend but for four years they wouldn't
let me in there it's a great Club
amazing but sometimes it can be a real
low-do drunken disaster for sure yeah
just right off there and my audience is
like but God the gothic people really
come and it's I love I want to do a
special there that's why you haven't
done that Paramount yet I did I did my
HBO special there and it was great but
the gothic is it's just cool it's a rock
Club it's on Broadway
kind of 500. oh perfect and it's great
and it's kind of it's got a really cool
look but you know as as a person from
Denver yeah you're always excited to
meet somebody else because there aren't
a lot of us in sort of the stand-up
Community but I think you probably meet
people from New York and you're like
[ __ ] this guy but you meet people and
then but the majority of New Yorkers I
think are really cool because especially
New York City there is this unspoken
thing where it's like if you can do it
here we can do it anyway it's like but
it's kind of like a surfer in Hawaii
yeah you know what I mean like New York
you came to play yeah
and in Boston it's nice because you're
like you're a quiet racist you're quite
correct well correct any town that
doesn't it doesn't you you can't get
away with nonsense right work in class
Town New York and Boston they're not
gonna laugh at you unless you [ __ ]
own it because they just go hey man I
work for a living what are you [ __ ]
saying I don't care how famous you are
nothing [ __ ] dummy like that's yeah
and I think you know there is a nice
thing about that but yeah a New York uh
audience will change drastically as to
how they feel about you when you say I
live in New York
yeah when you're like I live in
Manhattan I lived in there like outside
okay that's really hard yeah but if they
think oh this guy lives in Los Angeles
and he's just in town doing stuff yeah
[ __ ] this what the [ __ ] is this guy yeah
yeah well are you on tour TJ I am on
tour bring it up TJ Miller does not have
a website.com TJ Miller does not have a
website.com because I the guy on
tjmiller.com wanted two grand in like
2003. I said I guess you don't know how
search engines work you piece of [ __ ] he
didn't email me back Louisville so yeah
Louisville coming up I've got October
yeah
and then Washington DC the 20th and 21st
great area and yeah it's uh it's it's a
lot of fun so go TJ Miller does not
havewebsite.com Instagram is teenage
millionaire because that's how I dress a
little bit you used to wear chains a lot
more yeah
you're both you look like a high
schooler who's really confident but
before you leave you look in the mirror
for like a full 10 yeah yeah and I'm
like does this even work yeah I know the
fatigues yeah
look at that huh oh yeah Badger
[ __ ] right there the greatest
description I've ever heard yeah it
could be real could be real and then uh
not TJ Miller on Tick Tock and Twitter
as if somebody if people use that but
subscribe to my YouTube and the biggest
thing is watch dear Jones watch the
goddamn special share it dear Johnson
he's one of the funniest dudes in the
world from Denver yeah it is it's a
Colorado thing you guys hey Colorado
everyone from Colorado should watch
unless you're a terrorist how about that
exactly that's the message Mass shooter
if you're a mass shooter don't watch it
yeah I'm in San Jose this weekend yeah
you are San Jose Improv October 13th the
15th that's this Thursday Friday
Saturday next week I'm at uh tell your
pops come by so like Salt Lake City Wise
Guys
October 20th through the 22nd is Wise
Guys and then I end October in Calgary
I'm at the rooftop on the 27th on that's
a Thursday and then I added a show on
Friday though Thursday's almost sold out
Houston San Antonio and uh I'm sorry uh
November is in Texas San Antonio and
Houston get your tickets
f-a-t-k-z.com or thickboy.com this
weekend Bridgeport Connecticut Stress
Factory October 13 14 15. have you done
that you love this Factory yeah love it
Schaumburg Illinois Schaumburg Chicago
improv October not Chicago
so Comedy Zone Charlotte North Carolina
November 10 11 12 then Naples Florida
December one yeah I'll have the Hook's
really funny too because they're all
older but the guys like my name is
Captain Brian and you're like nice to
meet you Brian he's like Captain Brian
dude I went I went hey I'm almost 40 do
I have to tell you captain of this I'd
appreciate it yeah yeah cause he is I
went all right Captain he's a good guy
if he was a douchebag he's like it's a
captain like you're Brian [ __ ] he's
such a nice guy awesome Ryan Spina I
know he's such a nice guy you know we're
actually Real Deal stand-up comics
because everybody had to read where
their dates are that's how [ __ ]
insane our lives are that we're like
next weekend I'll be at Naples Florida
true you just have no idea and you don't
remember where you were people be like
where were you yeah last weekend you're
like
I don't uh you can check my website I
had [ __ ] Amnesia I was like I can't
oh no I just I just talked to the CT my
brother's like don't come over here last
year I'm like using my tour man like
remember no it doesn't open that often
but you guys sometimes you wake up and
you don't know where you are yes yes
you're like where am I exactly because
the hotel rooms all pretty much look the
same and then I did a thing I'm still
kind of doing it where I try and stay at
like a cool hotel that's what I've been
doing lately and it's good but it's like
you're still in a hotel so as a part of
me I don't need to yeah I do airbnbs
yeah do you really yeah yeah that's
brilliant I never thought about it it's
easier you don't feel as much on the
road yeah yeah that's really fun too
yeah right TJ we [ __ ] love you dude
dude go watch a special dear Jonah
Denver's finest I love it you're the
captain you guys to be on the fire and
the kids
we love you man don't really care for
the podcast listen to it certainly won't
listen to this episode because I was
there in it because I lived it it was a
doozy
so correct so yeah yeah this is my
favorite podcast ever TJ we love you
brother this is fine kid we're out